e
herkese merhaba Ben konuşmama bir soru
ile başlamak istiyorum Muhtemelen
ergenlik yaşlarımız dan itibaren
Hayatınız boyunca duymaya mahkum
kaldığımız bir soru bu kendinizi tanıyor
musunuz
17 yaşında artık üniversiteye hazırlanan
meslek seçimi yapacak Hayat gidiş altını
çizmeye çalışan biri olarak sürekli
Maruz kaldım bir soru basında kendinize
tanıyor musunuz
genellikle insanların Evet kendimi
tanıyorum diye cevap verdiğini duyabilir
gibiyim Fakat aslında Sizler kendinizi
tanıdığınızı Sancak kadar kendinizi
tanımıyorsunuz belki En sevdiğiniz rengi
En sevdiğiniz yemeği yapmaktan
hoşlandığın şeyler size burada sorsam
cevabını hızlıca verebilirsiniz fakat
Yaşınız kaç olursa olsun ileriki süreçte
gerçekten kim olmak istediğinizi biliyor
musunuz
4sınıf tabii Az önce hayat bilgisi ile
başlayıp sonradan sosyoloji psikoloji
Hatta devamlı Siz getirin birçok ders
var bu alanlarda bu şekilde dallanıp
budaklanmak sosyal bilimler derslerinde
kişilik lerimizin Yani beğenilerim izin
davranışlarımızın Yani genel olarak da
hayata karşı tutum uzun ailemiz
toplumumuz çevremiz nedeniyle
etkilendiğini ve şekillendiğini
biliyoruz belki ama bize hiçbir zaman
gerçekten kim olduğumuz ve neden öyle
olduğumuz sorgula atılmadı
yaşadıklarımızın neden yaşadığımızı ve
insanların ilişkilerimizde bize karşı
tutumlarını onların neden ara
davrandıklarını irdelemeye iyi Neden
sorusunu Aslında biraz da içimize döner
kendimize sormayı öğretmenler bizlere
hiç yaşadığımız her olumsuzlukta ya
karşımızdaki suçlamayı ya da onlara
kırılmayı seçtik Çünkü böyle öğrenmiştik
ama sonra büyüdük ki ben hala diyorum ve
birşeylerin de farkına varmaya başladı
var yani onu Bir şeylerin farkına
varmaya başlamıştır yaşadığımız her anda
tüm yaşantımızda Aslında bizlere
etkileyen her şeye karar veren de
hayatımızın gidişatını belirleyen de
sadece biz varız bu konuda çok fazla
Clash elası duyacaksınız ki
duymuşsunuzdur Muhtemelen birçok Aslında
tek soğukta dinleyebilirsiniz bu konuda
ama benim asla unutamayacağım bir şey
varsa o da annemin ki kendisi en büyük
rol modellerinden biridir bana
algılandığını kadarsın dişidir gerçekten
öyleyiz bakın bir düşünün yanlış
anlaşılmalar hiçbir zaman sadece tek
tarafın nedeniyle oluşacak durumlar
değildir iletişim kopuklukları da sadece
tek tarafın kapalı ile oluşacak durumlar
değildir burada önemli olan her
yaşantınızda Aslında o anı yaşayan o
anda farklı kişileri de etkileyen ve de
etkilenen kişilerin o taraflardan
birinin de olduğumuzu unutmamaktır ol bu
alanlarda bulunan ve olumsuzluklar
içinde dünyam bir insanın kalbindeki o
boşluk gittikçe nasıl artıyorsa kendini
iyi adammış huzurla donatmış hayatını
bir insanın da iletişim kalitesinin
Hayat kalitesinin karşısı ile kurduğu
ilişkilerin güzelleşmesi aslında aynı
kapıya çıkmakta bakarsınız Sonuçta
yaşadığımız her şeyi Biz etkili yoruz
bir düşünün Yarın önemli bir işiniz var
ve saatler
atıyorsunuz akşam yatıyorsun sabah
kalkıyorsun hazırlanın oluyorsunuz ve
çıkıyorsunuz evden çıktıktan sonra 10-12
dakika sonra farkına varıyorsunuz ki
artık o kombiniz ne sizi memnun ediyor
ne de o günü uygun bir şey bu kadar
küçük bir şey bile gününüzü negatif
etkilerken hayatımıza bakışımız ın
hayatımızda kendimizi koyduğumuz
konumuzun Hayat gibi şansımızı ve
yaşantımıza yansımasını bekleyemeyiz ki
sonuçta Peki hayat hayatımızın
gidişatını daha da güzelleştirmek için
konumu bu gireceksek bunu nasıl
yapacağız Maalesef ki çok satanlar
listesinde iki tane kişisel gelişim
kitabı Okumakla olmayan bir süreç Bak bu
süreçte insanın kendi konumunu
bulabilmesi için ve değerlendirilmesi
için öncelikle kendini bulması gerekiyor
ve insanın kendini bulma süreci de
maalesef sadece bir kere yapıp da atamam
Ben artık kendimi tanıyorum Her Şeyim
Tamam diyebileceğim bir süreç değil
hatta bu süreç Muhtemelen köpek
balıklarından korkan birinin Okyanus
dalışı yapmaya karar vermesinden veya
yüksekten korkan birinin ki onlardan bir
de ben oluyorum Selvi yapmaya karar
vermesinden daha da cesaret gerektiren
bir süredir Çünkü bu süreçte o zamana
kadar bildiğiniz doğrulardan o zamana
kadar belki de kabul ettirdiniz
ordulardan hayatımızın bir çoğunu
geçirmiş olduğunuz insanlardan ve o
zamana kadar da tanıdığımız Ve
karşımızdakiler de tanıttığınız ben
kişisinden o yanılsamadan vazgeçmeyi
göze almamız gerekecek bu süreç da
olabilir Biraz korkutucu bir süre
dediğimiz gibi birkaç kere yaşayacağımız
ve genellikle daha da korkutucu olacak
mı süreç ama Bunu da unutmamak gerekiyor
ki insanların bazen daha güzeli daha iyi
bulabilmesi için öncelikle bir şeyleri
kaybetmeyi göze alması gerekir Bu
süreçte de asıl önemli olay Aslında
kendinizi bulmaya çalışırken kendinizi
kaybetmekten korkmamaktır Çünkü
kendinizi tanımaya karar verdiğiniz o
anda ve kendini tanıtma sürecine
girdiğinizde o adını ilk haklarınız anda
karşınıza Aslında hayatımızın en büyük
ödülü çıkacak o eden ödül de sizin Ama
bu sefer gerçek kişiliğinizin aynada
gözüken altın yıldızlarla bezenmiş bir
yansıması olacak işte şimdi başlıyor
Aslında süreç Bu noktadan sonra o ayna
ile oynadı gördüğünüz yansımayla ne
yapacağımıza bağlı olarak da bir süreç
ilerleyecek hayatınız değişecek Çünkü
artık sizin o içinizdeki ışıltıyı
yansıtma mızda etrafınızda dolaşacak da
aynı parlaklar erişmiş olan insanlar
olacaktır artık ilişkilerine hayatına
tüm bakış açısına o altın parlaklığı
yansıtan da sizsiniz
Hayat kalitesi gelişen ilişkiler gelişen
sesiniz Ama burada da unutmamamız
gereken bir nokta var ki bu süreçte
değişen karşımızdakiler olmadı bu
süreçte değişen Aslında sesiniz o alsın
yağını Sanayi görüp onu benimsemeye
hayatına yansıtmayı seçenler Sizsiniz
yani takdir Aslında tamamen Sizlerde
Sonuçta karşımdaki kim olursa olsun yani
bu anneniz çocuğunu sevgiliniz ya da en
yakının bile dediğiniz kişi olsa da
onların gerçeklikleri ne belirleyen
sadece sizlersiniz o etken Sizsiniz
Çünkü karşınızdaki insanların
gerçeklikleri karşıya yüklediğiniz duygu
düşünce He silsilesine somutlaşmış
durumundan başka bir şey değil aslında
bu noktadan sonra karşınıza kim gelirse
olsun ya dünyanın en kötü insanı bile
olsa ama Artık karşına çıkan
olumsuzluklara Siz o altın parasını da
mas geleceğimizden düşmanımız bile olsa
karşınızdaki artık yıpratmaz işte asıl
güç dediğimizde bu içinde dönüp
kendimize iyice tanıyabilmek aynada
gördüğümüz o altın parası güzelce benim
sevilmek son olarak aynı yere bir daha
dönmek istiyorum Fakat bu sefer cevabını
verirken biraz beklemenizi rica edeceğim
Bu sorunun aynaya baktığınızda artık
altınlara bezenmiş kendi yansımamız
görebiliyor musunuz kendinizi tanıyor
musunuz bu noktadan sonra da artık altın
rengi En sevdiğiniz renk değilse Kişisel
tanımada artık biraz da adım atmamız
gerekiyor teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]